winter is coming and while the West hit
Moscow with sanctions over its support
for Ukrainian separatists Russia holds
the nozzle to heat homes across Ukraine
and Europe up to half of Ukraine's and a
third of Europe's gas supply comes from
Russia via pipeline and this is one of
the many issues that Ukraine and Russia
are fighting over often leaving
Ukrainians caught in the middle let's
rewind
in 2002 the Western military alliance
NATO began courting Ukraine to join the
ever expanding Atlantic trade alliance
it enraged Russia who see NATO as a
continuation of the Cold War and in 2008
threatened to aim nuclear missiles at
Ukraine if it joined in 2013 the EU
offered 610 million euros in budget
relief if Ukraine accepted loan terms by
the International Monetary Fund and
signed the EU free trade agreements
Russia threatened crippling economic
retaliation if Ukraine signed the deal
and offered a one-third discount in
natural gas and 15 billion bucks in
desperately needed cash as a reward for
rejecting European integration Kiev
sided with Europe and the country
descended into civil war
Russia has the look 3rd time in a decade
turned off the gas tap to Ukraine the
same gas that goes to Europe so this is
a double edged sword oil and gas sales
make up more than half of Russia's
government revenue and some of its
biggest clients are European countries
so is all of this saber-rattling serious
or will their economic codependence calm
the flames
and how many people in Eastern Europe
might be left in the cold this winter
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook